[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
the heat receiving the Bob Cousy award
and the Larry Bird conference MVP award
as Ernie Johnson said it's not lost on
me the irony of this but is it ironic
sad or hysterical
fritzy I think it's pretty hysterical to
me all right Seton
yeah I mean it was going to be my best
of the weekend I thought it was just I
was absolutely dying last night watching
and Ernie yeah he had a great line right
you know the irony here is not lost on
me Marv
oh hysterical all right Paulie yeah
hysterical that's that's a brutal
weekend and a holiday weekend in Boston
uh all the Bros were out all tanned up
everybody Prime for a historic night
ever yeah here's the here's the Larry
Bird trophy Jimmy it's bringing Dan
lebichard host of The Dan Le batard show
with Stu gontz and uh Dan good to see
you
it's always nice seeing you uh Dan I've
got a little bit of chaos around me here
we've got a very electric uh sort of
vibrating
uh Miami and we're coming off of a
historic uh United America last night
feeling very good about itself because
they were be they would be able to laugh
at one City last night was a winning
night for America either today would be
about laughing at Boston fans or
laughing at Miami fans and uh America
wins today and here's the best part
about it America was going to win today
no matter what one hated fan base was
going to allow you to laugh like that
today so congratulations to America yeah
but I don't know if America hates the
Miami Heat anymore
no no we're gonna need it we kind of
need it down here they hate Miami Dan oh
but not not the Heat
I believe that uh all things Miami
are something that divide America
do you guys hate the the Miami Heat like
Jimmy Butler is a great story and Caleb
Martin and Gabe Vincent and Eric
spolsterer and we need the hate we've
been starved for the hate since 2010 why
are you not understanding what's
happening around here wait the lights
just went out on your show oh my gosh
yeah haters what happened haters bring
back our hate okay
I'm sorry that the power has gone down
here I can still hear you though Dan I
can still hear you you never look better
I love it yeah anybody get any matches
yeah how about a candle I'm running I'm
running a media Empire here Ben Patrick
this is a very exciting time in our
history and everything shakes and creaks
down here with the enthusiasm we've lost
all power down here so I'm sorry this
isn't a better televised Affair do you
is this I like it I like it I like it by
candlelight
is this the lebatard Blair Witch Project
I uh I'm sorry that I literally after
leaving ESPN can't keep the lights on
gosh pay the bills for the man will you
you want me to pay the bill get out of
here I don't play my own bill actually
uh what would it be like today if the
Miami Heat had lost last night well
here's the thing though Dan do you know
what a gut punch game six was like when
do you ever see It'll Get forgotten by
time what would have been something that
in Boston would have rang Eternal like
Dave Roberts stealing a base and when
they were down 3-0 Derek white gets lost
to history now he's just they it was the
the reason I say this felt the way that
it did uh back when Miami and the world
were fighting is because everybody was
willing and ready to laugh at Miami
being the first to drop a 3-0 lead Derek
white doing that as a gut Punch If you
like sports you can hate Boston and
still be like man that was amazing what
an amazing ending and Boston would have
had that forever instead they had it for
two days it's gone now like it just it
is it evaporates into something like oh
my God that team was a laughing stock
and here's the best part if you want to
laugh at Boston Boston season ended on
the very next play when Jason Tatum
hurt his ankle like the very next time
they played a basketball play everything
that Derek white gave them was gone and
so it's just it's something you can
laugh at just like us losing the lights
here at a seminal moment in sports
history in South Florida where we've got
two eight seeds ruining Boston season
two eight seeds ruining everything
Boston wants to believe in as hope we
really hate Boston it's a legitimate
rivalry Dan we don't have those anymore
it's a legitimate rivalry those are the
best two teams in the East the last four
years and they hate each other going
back to Pat Riley hates Boston because
bleep Boston okay who's more important
to the Heat and their success Eric
spolster or Pat Riley
uh why do I have to choose you have to
choose I ask you to choose you look it's
sports radio exactly tell them DP I mean
okay Eric Spoelstra learned in the dark
crevices of the caves of whatever
obsessive compulsiveness sort of what
you're in right now a dark kid exactly
but in sports Eric's supposed to he was
spending years
sculpting in the dark recesses of the
film room before technology was good
like he's he's splicing up tape and he
comes through 30 years of that now what
is it seven seven finals or Eastern
Conference Finals whatever the numbers
are half the time they get that far and
it's all of it it's not just bolstery
it's bolster handed down from Riley
because he learned all the Riley stuff
and they still go face to face on
confrontation even though Riley's damn
near 80 years old well you answer the
man's question I mean I don't I mean who
built it Pat Riley built all of it okay
so stugots let me ask you yeah who's
more important
uh Eric Bolster in fact Dan I would tell
you that if Eric spolster has ever had
thoughts of going somewhere else because
he is tired of this question and tired
of being under the umbrella of Pat Riley
I would tell you after this season his
stock will never be higher because he
has made it to the finals with Jimmy
Butler as his best player and when you
consider what jobs are open right now
Eric spolsterer can say hey here's my
salary I want T president I want head
coach I want control of everything not
surprising go do it in Milwaukee
surprising that stugots would turn
supposed for winning into a leveraged
person how about well it is but how
about we stop giving Riley credit for
something that spolster is actually
doing okay and because spolster is on
the badge and he has coached these guys
that within four games of an NBA
champion okay but what I would also say
Dan is you see coaches who are on very
good teams a bunch of superstars are
available right now because Doc Rivers
came do Joel embiid uh you got Kevin
Durant gets Monty Williams fired there
are very good jobs available that are
never available and in Miami spolster
knows that the guy who was with him in
the video room is with him still because
he's got organizational stability behind
him it doesn't matter who you choose to
me
it doesn't he could have gone to
Portland gotten out ownership stake
could have been president could have had
power but he's been comfortable growing
old here learning what he's learned here
30 years of you saw Dan have you ever
seen after game six a coach
going into Boston for a game seven as an
eight-point dog banging on the table I
want to tip it up again right now right
now I wanna I wanna tip it up again like
you could give I don't know why we have
to separate the credit why do we have to
choose between them why can't it be
organizational this is a really strong
organization that has done more winning
this Century than the Celtics well you
know basketball's most historic
franchise see this is why I'm starting
to hate the heat again because people
like Dan lebatard telling me all that
and by the way don't take credit for the
Florida Panthers here Dan what do you
mean I mean aren't they closer to Boca
Raton
uh yeah well actually we were saying
that the uh boat parade is going to be
airport uh because they they exist in a
Marshland
it's aggressively uh I mean Sunrise
Florida that's where you go to die isn't
it
whoa I mean or the Sawgrass Mills Mall
good thing we have an expert in Greg
Cody here who lives right over there
that's correct exactly that's right
right near my house but you know what
I'll tell you what Dan Patrick uh expose
loyalty to the heat is baked in his
loyalty to Riley is baked in he's not
going anywhere he's not going anywhere
air exposure he's a heat lifer book it
that's our popular uh Greg Cody long
time uh total Homer yeah absolutely this
week he just gave you book it like it
was a 70s detective catchphrase thank
you book it yeah yeah put it in a book
write it down in a book the blanket how
big is Jimmy Butler if we had power
rankings in six in Miami
I know our athlete Power Rankings is he
a one seed
okay
[Laughter]
over anybody with the dolphins anybody
anybody else come into anybody from the
Florida Panthers okay you're talking
about uh present or all time
um how about current and then we could
do all the time okay but this is what we
need to do if we're gonna go to you know
can you put up a test pattern at least
on your screen there like something it's
just I I buddy I don't have control of
the technology here
it is embarrassing you don't think I'm
embarrassed right now do you think that
I'm filled with buoyant Champion Pride
right now this is why Mike Ryan left but
as you he hasn't left he just can't see
him because
in the dark I can see well he's gonna be
leaving yeah I'm leaving now yeah I
don't I get out get out while you can
answer your question this is why it's
funny the question that you just asked
yes Jimmy Butler is in the process of
trying to wrestle away the Legacy and
team of the Miami Heat from Dwyane Wade
gave us the greatest feeling and LeBron
James gave us the greatest feeling
however in the last two games Caleb
Martin has been their star Caleb Martin
has been their best player over the last
few games our Michael Jordan has been
outplayed by Caleb Martin over the last
half he should have been the MVP last
night well that's Reggie Miller's fault
he said
is to yell at me right now
because Reggie Miller told us on the
broadcast last night surprise the audio
works there out of that studio
goodness gracious man did you see me at
all no
it's a dark screen why am I holding
these lights
he's been holding the phone to his face
for 15 minutes
for 12 minutes you have been in the
black and in the dark
you can't see me at all no
the power's out in the building this is
great I have no idea how we're connected
to Dan Patrick honestly
it's hot in here too all right well now
I'm now I'm here now you don't have any
signal here coming oh my God I feel bad
for you Meadowlark beautiful
hiring now firing now as media falls
apart all over the United States how
about technicians hiring technicians
right now a lighting director something
like that you got to start with the
basics a good foundation Dan a brand new
studio I'm sure it wasn't cheap then I'm
sure it wasn't oh no I saw the tour I
saw the tour of the studio look great
do you know how hard it is to pay rent
and buy things in Miami right now
you know how expensive things are here
stugots Greg Cody and Dan Le batard make
up that Powerhouse show the Dan lebatard
show with stugontz and they you know
what you're on to something a blackout
show you know we see we see audiences do
it you've done it with the show
congratulations Dan I'm deeply
embarrassed
man he's falling on Hard Times
left ESPN
yeah
feel bad